在这一课,我们将开始用最简单的一个Agentic RAG, 一个运作机。
在运作中,运作机将选择了 许多运作机来执行运作。
你将建立一个简单的运作机, 与一个单独的文件, 能够解决问题和解决问题。
让我们进入。
在运作中,运作机将选择了 许多运作机来执行运作。
因此,这给予你一些 极端的运作机理解释。
我们将展示如何建立 一个简单的运作机,
与一个单独的文件, 能够解决问题和解决问题。
我们将展示如何建立 一个简单的运作机, 与一个单独的文件, 与一个单独的文件。
我们将展示如何建立 一个简单的运作机, 与一个单独的文件。
我们将展示如何建立 一个单独的运作机, 与一个单独的文件。
接下来的步骤是选择的,这让我们找到LLM和Embedding的模式。
你可以用一个全球的Config设施,
将LLM和Embedding的模式设定为全球的Config的一部分。
我们在这一课中使用3.5 Turbo和TaxEmbedding ETA-002,
但这可以让你基本上把自己的LLM和Embeddings设施进行。
我们将设定设置的构图,
SETTINGS.LLM=OPENAI,SETTINGS.Embedding_MODEL=OPENAI_EMBEDDING。
现在我们准备开始设置一些构图。
这里我们设定两个构图在这些构图上。
这包括了一个数据构图和一个构图构图。
我们可以以一个数据构图为一个设置的设备。
您可以录取一个构图,
而不同的构图将有不同的录取行为。
一个构图,与其他构图同样,可以通过TaxEmbeddings
和LLM构图和其他构图建立Rag系统的构图。
设置一个构图将带来最相似的构图通过EmbeddingSimilarity。
一个数据构图,在另一方面,也是一个很简单的构图,
但设置它将带来所有的构图目前在构图中,
所以它并不必要根据用户图,
但将带来所有在构图目前在构图中的构图中的构图。
在设置构图和构图数据上,
这些两个简单的构图是很重要的。
现在让我们把这些数据移到迷录机上,
然后到迷录工具上。
每个迷录工具代表整个迷录工具
在这个迷录工具内存在的数据中,
并且与LLM的迷录工具互动。
每个迷录工具都适合某种问题,
这可以让迷录工具与这些不同的迷录工具互动。
一个迷录工具现在仅仅是迷录工具的迷录工具,
特别是迷录工具能够解决哪些问题的详细解决。
在这里,我们把数据迷录工具等于数据迷录工具当作迷录工具,
还有数据迷录工具等于数据迷录工具当作迷录工具。
我们可以看到迷录工具是从每个迷录工具中取得的,
我们可以看到迷录工具的数据迷录工具,我们设定用AsyncEqualsTrue,
以基本上提供更快的迷录工具,以提升迷录工具的能力。
接下来,迷录工具只是迷录工具,它是一个特别的描写,
它可以解决哪些问题的类型,
我们将设定迷录工具为迷录工具和迷录工具的与数据迷录工具。
在这里的这个数据迷录工具,我们可以看到迷录工具的描写,
它是用于与MetaGPT相关的简单解决问题,
和迷录工具的描写是用于取得特定的 context 从MetaGPT的文件中。
现在我们有了迷录工具和工具,我们已经准备了我们的迷录工具。
Lama Index 提供了许多不同的类型的选择,
以让你能够建立迷录工具,
而每个选择中有不同的特征。
LLM 选择是一个选项,它涉及迷录工具提供迷录工具的迷录工具,
然后它们的选项是迷录工具。
另一个选项是使用Pydantic 选择。
而不是直接提供迷录工具,
我们实际上是使用功能迷录工具支援的API,
以使用Pydantic 选择的工具,
而不是直接提供迷录工具。
每个选择中,
我们也有丰富的能力让你选择一个Route 2 计算器,
或者数量计算器。
我们试试LLM 充电单选项,
叫做LLM 单选项。
所以,我们拥有两个计算器,
我们拥有Router Query Engine,
以及LLM 单选项。
您可以看到,Router Query Engine 将拥有选项类型,
以及一套迷录工具。
您看到的选项类型只是LLM 单选项,
这意味着,它提供了LLM 单选项,
而迷录工具含有丰富的数量计算器,
以及迷录工具。
现在,让我们试试迷录工具。
我们会问的第一个问题是,
迷录工具的数量是什么?
迷录工具可以让我们观看
迷录工具丰富的步骤。
我们看到迷录工具含有
选择迷录工具丰富的数量计算器。
这意味着,第一个选项,
迷录工具,是选择的,
以帮助解决这个问题。
结果,您能够提供迷录工具。
文件中介绍了迷录工具,
LLM 单选项的迷录工具。
这提供了迷录工具的整体数量,
与迷录工具的各种词汇。
迷录工具带有分类,
以检查这些数字,
我们可以观看迷录工具丰富的数量。
我们观看迷录工具丰富的数量时,
我们看到迷录工具丰富的数量是34。
这意味着,这与迷录工具的数量
与迷录工具丰富的数量相同。
我们看到迷录工具丰富的数量
应该被召集,
因为迷录工具丰富的数量
将所有与迷录工具丰富的数量
与迷录工具丰富的数量相同。
我们来看看另一个例子。
我们会问,
如何与其他人分享信息?
让我们问问整体的Router Query Engine
看看与回答的与绿色的出现。
这里我们看到我们选择了Query Engine 1,
LM给我们一些理解,
为何我们选择了Mector Search Tool,
而不是Summary Tool。
因为它专注于与MetaGPT的情况,
与其他人分享信息的专家
可能在那笔文章里面。
我们可以找到这个情况,
并且与回答。
这样,我们可以利用一个共同信息的功能,
让他们可以发布与绿色的信息。
这基本上就能结束LM1。
为了把所有东西放在一起,
所有的文件在上面可以变成一只帮助器,
将一条文件的路线进行,
并建立Router Query Engine,
与它与Vector Search与Summary Tool与其他人分享。
我们把这些东西当作帮助器,
让你们试试看。
如果您想把自己的PDF与信息放进去,
就这样做吧,
并且看看结果。
这是在Utils的Module里面,
叫做GatRouter Query Engine。
我们只需要做"Query Engine=GatRouter Query Engine,MetaGPT.PDF"。
我们可以测试一个例子。
我们的例子是,
"告诉我关于Ablation的结果读书,
我们复制Query Engine,
并复制回回答。"
在这些情况下,
我们也能看到Query Engine 1,
因为Ablation的结果读书
与MetaGPT的特定的情况之间,
所以我们想要做Vector Search,
并复制回回答。
这就是我们的第一课,
我们下一个课吧!